rumor is running right that lady gaga
might just be taking on the role of
harley quinn in the sequel to joker but
what might she look like in the role and
can she ever hold a candle to her iconic
predecessor keep watching to find out
considering the huge success of 2019's
joker it might not come as much of a
surprise to learn that a sequel is in
development more surprising though is
the buzz from the hollywood reporter
that indicates lady gaga could be
joining the film as dr harleen quinzel
aka harley quinn reportedly the actress
and pop star is in talks to appear in
the film alongside joaquin phoenix's
joker the title of the movie joker foley
ado suggests the movie will see arthur
fleck joined by a partner in crime as
the title refers to a medical term about
shared mental illness the hollywood
reporter claims that gaga's character
name is technically being kept under
wraps but it's difficult to say who else
besides harley quinn she could be
playing in a potential sequel especially
one with this title whatever happens a
sequel appears to be in good hands as
director todd phillips has written the
script with joker co-writer scott silva
and phoenix is expected to return
meanwhile fans are already excited at
the prospect of gaga as queen and one
particular piece gives a stunning look
at how gaga could look as gotham's queen
of crime in an artwork posted to
instagram renowned fan artist boss logic
posted an animated rendering of gaga as
harley quinn featuring a fresh take on
the character's famous costume as one
instagram user commented this looks
badass perfect combo another said
she's amazing nice work boss others
however don't seem to be quite so
convinced about gargar's potential
casting as harley quinn while the
musician has built an impressive acting
resume in the last few years she would
have some challenges to face if she were
to step into the role namely the fact
that another actor has become
practically synonymous with the
character even with the mixed reception
to 2016 suicide squad many fans were
thrilled by margot robbie's portrayal of
harley quinn she went on to appear in
her own spin-off and james gunns a
suicide squad sequel and she's won
praise for her performances each and
every time while it may be hard to
imagine another actress taking over the
role it's important to remember just how
many actors have played the joker over
the years phoenix still managed to blow
audiences away and nab a best actor
academy award for his 2019 performance
even though the role had previously been
brought to the screen by a number of
other actors robbie herself suggested at
one point that she needed a break from
the role of quinn in the run-up to the
release of the suicide squad however she
suggested she's ready for more are you
gonna take a little break from harley no
i've had enough of the break i'm ready
to do her again of course if gaga does
play harley in the joker sequel she
would not be a full replacement for
robbie because robbie's quinn exists in
the dc eu gaga would simply represent
another version of quinn from dc's
expanding multiverse lady gaga's
involvement isn't the only revelation to
come out about joker foley ado however
according to the hollywood reporter the
movie could also end up being a musical
it would certainly be an original way to
follow up the original and todd phillips
gamble paying off for the first movie
likely gave warner brothers some faith
in trying something different this time
around while it wasn't a musical philips
and gaga have worked on a music heavy
movie in the past phillips was a
producer on bradley cooper's a star is
born the oscar-winning film that also
gave gaga a hit with shallow well the
joker foley ado does end up being a
full-blown musical or not though gaga's
inclusion at least opens a possibility
of including some kind of fitting
musical element and hey we already know
phoenix's joker can dance so this really
could be a match made in heaven or at
least whatever arkham asylum version of
heaven might be
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]